In the last episode, we traced some of the
major influences of werewolf legends back
thousands of years in Europe and looked at
how Christianity and real-world tragedies
positioned the wolf shapeshifter as a demonic
threat—fears that ultimately culminated
in the torture and execution of humans rumored
to be werewolves.
There’s usually a fine line between fact
and fiction when it comes to monsters — So
when did the threat of werewolves become something
largely resigned to the pages of fiction?
During the industrialization, urbanization,
and rapid scientific advancement of the 19th
century, the werewolf was increasingly positioned
as literary fantasy rather than a real threat.
The werewolf slunk back into antiquity, a
symbol of the past.
But the modern literature and the silver screen
re-invigorated the werewolf legend.
Most contemporary ideas and conceptions of
the werewolf became dominated and driven by
film—and they still are.
We’ve moved the werewolf from the realms
of mythology, from tales of warriors and witches
to a pop culture icon.
Given the large scope of the folklore collection
of Brothers Grimm, it’s not surprising that
their 1812 anthology of German folklore includes
the story of a man who transforms into a werewolf
using a special belt.
Variations of this story became the “most
common” werewolf story in Germany at the
time.
The popularity of the Grimm Brothers publications
helped launch the werewolf into mainstream
literature.
The first werewolf in a 19th-century novel
appears around the time of the Grimm tales
too;
in an 1824 historical Romance titled The Albigenses.
Written by Irish Gothic novelist Charles Robert
Maturin and set in the 13th century,
a character within the text wakes from a nightmare
to find himself under attack by a “lycanthrope”
with “fiery eyes, white fangs, and claws”
who is in a “horrid frenzy” that causes
him to act with “desultory wolfish[ness].”
Later the attacker confesses “I am a fangless
wolf” a “wolf-man” although he says
his fur grows on the inside.
The Gothic genre continued to evolve alongside
and influence the pulpy penny dreadfuls, cheap
volumes of weekly serialized sensational and
violent stories—the perfect place for the
first savage werewolf transformation.
First serialized as a penny dreadful and published
as a collected text in 1847, “Wagner the
Wehr-Wolf” is often considered the first
English text to have a werewolf as its main
character.
Set in Germany it opens with a mysterious
man offering the elderly Wagner the chance
to be young and handsome again, to have great
fortunes and intelligence to rival his riches.
But there are two conditions, the old man
must be the stranger’s companion for a year
and a half and he must “prey upon the human
race” as a Wehr-Wolf.
Wagner accepts the offering and drinks the
contents of a small vial the stranger provides
him.
He loses consciousness,
but upon waking the old man is not only young
but preternaturally healthy and intelligent.
It is later revealed that the deal he made
was with John Faust and Wagner is now immortal
but must turn into a werewolf once a month.
And the description of that change is intense.
Convulsing horribly and shrieking, Wagner’s
body elongates from its human form “into
one of savage and brute-like shape.”
His beautiful clothes become “rough, shaggy,
and wiry skin” and with a howl of misery
he becomes a “monstrous wolf.
After the mid-19th century, werewolf accounts
in literature were often presented as some
kind of backward or “strange” local value
of the lower class, and the creatures were
dismissed by rational explanation.
An example of this is found in the first academic
study of werewolves in the English language—Sabine
Bering-Gould’s 1865 Book of Were-wolves:
Account of a Terrible Superstition.
The Anglican priest’s folklore collection
claimed that while werewolf legends were present
across all nations, they could all be explained
as real cases of human violence that inspired
monstrous behavior, usually, cannibalism brought
on by madness.
The book did collect werewolf tales from a
variety of historical and folkloric sources,
serving as a werewolf anthology of sorts.
And while science and religion continued to
try to explain away these stories, people’s
appetite for salaciousness and escapism wasn’t
going anywhere.
The creature's variations inspired fresh narratives,
like the introduction of the seductive female
werewolf.
In the late nineteenth century stories of
female werewolves with white fur appeared.
The attacks of these white she-wolves correspond
to the sudden appearance of a beautiful, young
stranger.
This woman’s real werewolf identity is often
indicated when in her human form by her unusual
eyes and penchant for wearing white fur.
Many stories like “The White Wolf of Kostopchin”(1889),
“The Were-Wolf,” (Housman; 1896), and
“The Other Side” (Stenbock; 1893) solidified
the presence of the female werewolf in horror—another
beautiful and sexually threatening creature—contributing
to the already established role of supernaturally
monstrous women in Gothic literature.
At the turn of the century, mostly as a result
of increased attention towards psychology,
werewolves became more associated with the
idea of a “beast within,” a hidden illness
or monstrous personality concealed by a veneer
of civility.
They also reverted back to being almost exclusively
male.
The reason for this is the more frequent depiction
of female victims, starting with Richard Bagot’s
novel A Roman Mystery in 1899, which detailed
a male werewolf's lurid attack on his sister-in-law.
The helpless woman attacked by the sexually
aggressive wolfman proved to be a popular
take in penny dreadfuls, pulp magazines, and
novels, and eventually—film.
Movies definitely changed the werewolf in
popular imagination.
You look back centuries ago, 16th century
France, even before and after.
But werewolf legends from centuries ago were
often based around serial killers that terrorized
the land.
The Beast of Gevaudan or the Werewolf of Dole,
these were based on men that were serial killers
and slaughtered, and folklore was a means
of exploring and understanding those acts
by transforming them into literal monsters.
Movie depictions internalized that.
It put the murderer and the unwitting accomplice
into one body fighting for control, in a way.
It made that all about an internal battle,
so it has an inherently tragic nature about
that.
Even with thousands of years of European lore
to draw from, the first werewolf movies instead
appropriated and bastardized the legends of
the indigenous peoples of North America.
The first motion picture to feature a werewolf
is the 1913 silent film The Werewolf.
We only know about cinema’s first werewolf
from movie reviews and historical documents;
the film was destroyed by a massive fire at
Universal Studios in 1924.
In the film, a Dinée (Navajo) woman marries
a white man.
After he is killed, she is led to believe
he abandoned her and in anger, she becomes
a witch and raises their daughter to hate
white men.
The daughter grows up and leads a revolt against
a group of friars for safeguarding the jealous
white man who killed her lover.
During the confrontation, she turns into a
wolf after being shown a crucifix.
The following year in 1914, The White Wolf,
again borrowed from a skewed perception of
indigenous legend.
The film portrays another scorned lover, this
time an indigenous medicine man,” demands
the hand of a woman who does not return his
affections.
With the help of her lover, the medicine man
is caught in his wolf form and transforms
back into a human.
Alas, we don’t know exactly how the transformation
is depicted since this film too has been lost
to time.
Both films clearly demonize non-white populations,
a theme that permeated many American horror
films of the early 20th century.
These horror and werewolf films were made
in the shadow of federal policies that persecuted
indigenous populations including the seizing
of their native lands and the establishment
of mandatory Christian boarding schools.
The earliest surviving werewolf film is Wolfblood.
Released in 1925 and it is the first known
depiction of a White werewolf in North America
on screen—although it is left to the audience
to decide if he really is a wolf shapeshifter
or is suffering from clinical lycanthropy.
In it, a man living in a remote logging camp
receives a life-saving blood transfusion from
a tame female wolf.
After the successful procedure, rival loggers
are killed in a wolf attack, and rumors begin
to swirl that the lupine blood in the man’s
veins transformed him into a werewolf.
Distraught by the accusation and haunted by
dreams of running with a pack of wolves, the
man tries to kill himself.
Other early 20th-century films contribute
significantly to the modern werewolf canon.
The Werewolf of London (1935) which is the
first on-screen depiction of a werewolf’s
bite transforming another human into a werewolf.
The Werewolf of London is Universal Studios
first foray into werewolf films.
In the movie, East Asia is the source of the
werewolf curse—the main character, botanist
Dr. Wildred Glendon, is bitten in Tibet by
a werewolf while collecting a rare flower
under the full moon.
Ironically, he is told by fellow botanist
Dr. Yogami, played by a Scottish actor in
yellowface, who tells Dr. Glendon that the
flower is the only thing that can cure his
werewolf curse.
Glendon rampages through London in wolf form
and discovers that Yogami is the werewolf
that bit him and the two werewolves fight.
Glendon prevails but survives only long enough
to be shot by Scotland Yard and transform
back into his human body as he takes his final
breath.
1935 lacked the special effects technology
to turn an actor into a realistic-looking
wolf; so The Werewolf of London created a
hybrid-man-wolf monster with predominantly
human features—although much hairier.
Scholars read this film as a representation
of repressed homosexuality, a warning against
the potential dangers of scientific advancement,
the uncontrolled spread of infectious disease,
and the growing fear of the growing East Asian
population in the Western world.
The film hit theatres the same week as Bela
Lugosi and Boris Karloff films [Mark of the
Vampire and Bride of Frankenstein] and The
Werewolf of London was quickly overshadowed
by the already popular monsters: a vampire
and Frankenstein’s Creature.
But luckily Universal didn’t give up on
the werewolf genre quite yet.
A few years later Universal introduced the
Wolf Man in a series of films, leading to
another werewolf surge.
Now, the plot of the
Wolfman from 1941 is particularly interesting
to me because of the traits and the tropes
that it brings about that still retain our
retain today and how we understand the modern
idea of the werewolf.
So we start with Lon, Chaney Jr.
A rather hapless American coming over to Wales
in order to inherit his family seat.
Traveling characters recur again, and again,
again as, um, vehicles of the supernatural,
whether that's because they have a certain
amount of knowledge that the irrational Western
mind does not have, or whether that's because
they themselves are infected or monstrous
in some way.
Now it's particular that I use the term infected
because the transformation is due to a bite.
And of course, we now understand that werewolves
transform because you get bitten and then
you get infected and then become a werewolf.
And sure enough, we have launched shiny junior
transforming at a full moon, which again is
the real truth that we see in Wells today.
But also not just that, not being aware of
what he's done.
Now, although he isn't killed by a silver
bullet, he's beaten to death by his father
as it happens.
There is an element of tragedy there because
they simply can't control what they are doing.
And so again, when we look at texts nowadays,
although the death of the beast, the destruction
of the violent animalistic trait, violent,
animalistic monster is necessary.
It's not always meant with Matt with absolute
happiness.
There is a question of whether we all selves
could find ourselves guilty of things that
we're not aware that we're doing.
The release of the first of these films in
1941 featured the more enduring human-looking
werewolf interpretation.
They were likable characters that became the
villains in their own stories through, often,
no fault of their own.
That set them apart.
It was a transformation of successful people,
to varying degrees, unraveling, thanks to
unwanted and terrifying changes in their own
body.
That makes them more relatable than your average
movie monster.
And then on top of that, you have remarkable
effects, in both cases of the Werewolf of
London and The Wolf Man.
Jack Pierce did both of those makeups.
And it brought that internal battle, that
loss of control, to the forefront.
It crystallized the tragic horror.
It gave it visual, a more textual approach,
through seeing that transformation.
In history, real monsters appropriate the
ones we talk about here.
After World War I, soldiers in the German
military
who refused to disband at the end of the war
joined together under the moniker ‘wehrwolf.’
The unit would go on to become an elite Nazi
recruiting source in World War II.
Werewolves were consciously integrated into
the Nazi Party,
borrowing from older German myths to create
propaganda that reflected Hitler’s notorious
obsession with the supernatural and the occult;
he even used ‘Wolf’ as a pseudonym for
himself.
As World War II came to an end, the Nazis
launched multiple campaigns inspired by the
lupine beast.
In 1944 they developed “Operation Werewolf,”
a mass poisoning plot that was never successfully
implemented,
although declassified documents from the National
Archives in Britain show that the supplies
of American and British troops were targeted.
Then in 1945, a “werewolf forces” unit
was created with the intent of putting volunteer
German fighters secretly behind enemy lines,
borrowing the name from the plot of the 1910
German novel Der Wehrwolf—a book that became
a bestseller in Nazi Germany.
These Nazi Werewolf operations would not be
examined in fiction until much later; the
real and lasting effect of the horrors of
the Nazi Regime made that impossible.
With the end of the War and the new atomic
era, a timely werewolf appeared—the scientifically
created nuclear experiment werewolf.
In 1956, moviegoers were introduced to the
human-to-wolf transformation caused by irradiated
wolf blood in The Werewolf—adding nuclear
experimentation into the werewolf canon.
Other anxieties of the decade were explored
in I Was a Teenage Werewolf (1957), often
read as a commentary on the fear of increasing
juvenile delinquency.
In the movie, a troubled and violent teenager
Tony becomes a werewolf after a hypnotherapist
injects him with an experimental serum.
The movie was a massive success, particularly
with young adult audiences, a new postwar
economic power.
This movie is arguably the first-ever to cater
specifically to the teen demographic.
Although certainly, it would not be the last.
In fact, since the 1950s many narratives containing
werewolf characters—from Teen Wolf to Ginger
Snaps , Harry Potter to Twilight—have aimed
for a teenage audience.
In 1964, television saw its first small-screen
and comedic werewolf in the character of Eddie
Munster.
Another popular horror-comedy series Dark
Shadows also included werewolves, further
expanding the monster’s influence as its
small-screen representations engaged new audiences—and
for the first time made werewolves funny.
Werewolf films of the 1960s and 70s were dominated
by narratives that depicted rising countercultures,
(Werewolves on Wheels),
the dismantling of the nuclear family (The
Boy Who Cried Werewolf),
and even the corruption behind the Watergate
scandal (The Werewolf of Washington).
Globally, werewolf films of the 70’s took
on changing sexual politics in parallel to
the growing sexual revolution (British Legend
of the Werewolf, 1975) with plots featuring
promiscuous female victims and murderous prostitutes.
The advancement of special effects and a growing
appreciation for its artistry helped birth
the violent transformation scenes that would
become a hallmark of werewolf films of the
1980s.
The audience’s fascination with the grotesque
change from human to werewolf also corresponds
to growing stigmas around changes in the body
that could occur with aging, fitness, and
diet.
1980’s werewolf films also took up ideas
of class—showing that idealized suburbs
were not the safe havens governments and popular
media portrayed them to be.
The 1981 film The Howling, loosely adapted
from a 1977 book, depicts an entire resort
full of werewolves.
It became inherently more terrifying in the
idea that it wasn't just one werewolf/serial
killer stalking a protagonist, Karen White.
She finds herself in the lions' den, so to
speak, of an entire werewolf colony.She's
isolated and trapped, and those she loves
most are also becoming werewolves around her.
So that was a pretty big push forward into
expanding beyond the one werewolf, you have
werewolves.
The movie was groundbreaking for its use of
special effects makeup showing the full transformation
from man to beast.
Rob Bottin's close-up transformation with
the bladder effects,
it just not only added a layer of creepiness
and made this villain even just more intimidating,
but there is something very painful about
that, too.
It brings a physicality to the dual nature
of being a werewolf.
Special effects makes being afflicted with
lycanthropy something harrowing and terrifying.
It captures the body horror of what that means
to become a werewolf in this very impressive
way.
Also released in 1981, An American Werewolf
in London borrows from European werewolf lore
and references historical explanations for
the monster.
After being wounded by a werewolf, the main
character David deteriorates mentally as the
full moon waxes.
The film alludes to a demonic cause behind
the original werewolf transformation
,a metaphorical inner beast, and even a vision
David has of mutant Nazi werewolves—drawing
supernatural Nazi werewolves into the horror
movie genre for the first time.
The werewolf’s dramatic presence continued
steadily into the 1990s Eighteen movies with
a myriad of werewolf characters were released
during the decade,
including a modern take on the ‘Werewolf
Lover’ myth [Meridian; 1990].
R.L. Stine’s Goosebumps series alone included
eight werewolf stories between 1995 and 1999.
Buffy the Vampire Slayer’s loveable Oz fought
alongside the Slayer, proactively caging himself
during the full moon.
The 1990s marked the popularity of the werewolf
in another form of media—video games.
While 1988’s Altered Beast holds the title
for the first video game with a werewolf character,
games of the 90s fully embraced and embellished
the monster.
Hungry audiences demanded more—and werewolf
popularity skyrocketed, ushering in a renaissance
the monster hadn’t seen in centuries.
And the growing werewolf obsession really
reached its pinnacle—with Alvin and the
Chipmunks Meet the Wolfman.
Kidding.
It’s terrible.
I’m really talking about the Canadian film
Ginger Snaps.
Released in 2000 Ginger Snaps both honors
and transforms the previous two decades of
werewolf cinema.
The film explicitly portrays werewolfism as
a sexually transferable condition and directly
relates female puberty to monstrosity,
both firsts for the monster—it’s freaking
awesome.
I think that a lot of the modern werewolf
owes a debt to Ginger Snaps.
That movie opened up the possibility of what
a werewolf's dual nature could mean.
It's no longer just a man fighting off his
inner beast or resisting his darker impulses
or trying to fight off a desire to kill.
Now it can be a woman experiencing the changes
that come with puberty.
It could be an exploration of burgeoning sexuality.
It could be an exploration of aging, mortality
even.
The story, set in a seemingly idyllic suburb
of Toronto, follows teen Goth sisters, Ginger
and Brigitte.
Ginger is bitten by a werewolf, triggering
a transformation directly linked to her menstrual
cycle.The film addresses teenage self-mutilation,
suicidal thoughts, and violence at school—a
plot point that came under scrutiny since
its release followed the 1999 Columbine and
W.R. Myers High School shootings.
The movie also addresses mental illness in
young adults—which came front and center
in the 1990s as psychiatric drugs were increasingly
prescribed to minors.
The film’s 2004 sequel would go on to address
drug addiction through the werewolf’s dependence
on intravenous treatment to curb her transformation
and violent desires.
In 1999, JK Rowling used her Professor Lupin
werewolf character as a metaphor for illnesses
with social stigmas, like HIV.
The werewolf also continued to reflect real-world
anxiety when post- 9/11 we saw an increase
in military were- narratives featuring military
and werewolf conflicts (Dog Soldiers, 2002;
War Wolves, 2009, Battledogs, 2013; Silverhide,
2015), using werewolf lore to explore themes
like PTSD, corrupt military officials, secret
government weapons, and even the War on Terror.
Long removed from real accusations of witchcraft
and theological discourse, the 21st century
produced more werewolf interpretations than
ever seen before.
Vampire-werewolf hybrids [Marcus and Michael
Underworld],
Jughead as a werewolf [Jughead: The Hunger]
magical hides that contain eternal werewolf
spirits [The Order],
werewolf Sims, packs of cartoon werewolf pups
[Hotel Transylvania],
aggressively muscular werewolves [Van Helsing],
the list goes on—it seems like werewolves
haven’t been this talked about since the werewolf trials.
In regard to Twilight, Stephanie Mayer does
something that we have seen done time and
time again.
And that is the misappropriation of native
American culture, which is entwined with folklore
about or beliefs in or narratives of werewolves
to give them a certain authenticity.
Although the way the Meyer uses this is very
problematic as incredibly racist.
It makes all sorts of assumptions.
I think what it also does is it shows us something
made, did not invent this.
It shows us something that has been occurring
for a long time,
This shows how settling cultures or colonizing
cultures have absorbed.
They have misappropriated, they have cannibalized
indigenous beliefs in order to give F a gift,
a veneer of authenticity to new narratives.
On-screen Teen Wolf, True Blood, Vampire Diaries,
Hemlock Grove, Van Helsing, and Penny Dreadful
showed audiences attractive werewolves battling
other supernatural creatures and coming to
terms with their “true” nature.
But not all modern werewolves inspire NSFW
fanfiction.
With so much history shadowing the werewolf,
I wanted to know what creating a new story
looks like today, so I asked Olivia Stephens,
graphic novelist and comic writer, who just
released a new YA werewolf graphic novel Artie
and the Wolf Moon.
I want to start off by saying I’m not a
traditional werewolf fan… a lot of my enthusiasm
for werewolves isn’t from the werewolf media
I consume but from wolves as an animal.
So for me, werewolves represent a deep relationship
to nature…achieving balance…vehicle for
community and family building.
These werewolf stories demonstrate another
modern werewolf trend—the werewolf pack.
The pack is portrayed as a tight-knit community
often at war with a rival pack (Blood and
Chocolate, 2007)
or engaged in conflict with another supernatural
species (Underworld, Twilight, Teen Wolf;
What We Do In the Shadows, True Blood).
The importance of the pack and of community
for survival, is present in real wolf populations,
and human ones as well—providing ample material
for supernatural metaphor.
I structured the narrative so that while it
is ultimately a story about werewolves and
vampire, it also isn’t—its about a lot
of things…
tension of werewolves who come from escaped
slaves to largely white vampire coven who
use hypnosis and other means to target that
community, and sow distrust and paranoia in
that community that is a mirror to the story
in a number of ways.
So in this reading vampirism is representative
of white supremacy and white supremacy as
a death cult, its an ideology whose members
seek to one, destroy intercommunity relationships,
two, to burden the marginalized, and three,
not even to place much value in their own
lives…and refuse to acknowledge our interconnectedness
as people.
In the last decade, we’ve seen plenty of
comedic werewolves,
cartoon werewolves,
and grotesque werewolves as well.
We’ve seen more than 50 films and countless
books and comics for audiences of all ages
featuring werewolf characters.
And there’s no indication that the trend
is slowing down—in fact, it’s the opposite.
But where will werewolves take us next?
I’m looking forward to tenderness.
I’m excited for tender and sensitive werewolves.
Basically, anything that spits in the face
of the violent wolfman losing control.
As we become more aware about wolves and the
natural world and what systems might be the
real monsters in all of this I want to see
far we can stretch that concept until it snaps.
I think Olivia is on to something.
In the last 10 years, real-world reports of
werewolf sightings have increased.
Beginning in 2015, the British press ran stories
about ‘Old Stinker,’ ‘The Beast of Barmston
Drain,” a wolf with a human face and terrible
breath who seemed to terrorize only women
and the occasional dog.
But this was not his first appearance.
In the 1960s he appeared nearby in Flixton,
as “an ancient wolf-like creature” walking
upright with an unusually long tail he would
knock people over with.
This resurgence of werewolf sightings in Great
Britain is particularly strange given the
country’s general lack of werewolf folklore.
Since wolves have long been absent from England,
how do we explain the recent sightings of
the werewolf known as ‘Old Stinker?’
Are pop culture and the broader distribution
of movies, literature, video games, and Internet
lore the inspiration behind this 21st-century
werewolf?
Well, only partially.
The place where ‘Old Stinker’ has been
spotted, an area called Hull, also happens
to be the last reported habitat of wolves
in England.
The same areas are also now undergoing massive
ecological changes.
Using an eco Gothic lens.
We can perhaps offer other alternatives to
what the werewolf can give us.
What this hybrid monsters hybrid monster can
show us is that being both is not scary.
(16:08) It is a great opportunity for us
to understand what humanity and what Wolf
means and what these identities can offer.
For a long time, Wolves have been symbols
of the ravaging and rapacious wilderness.
And then more recently they'd be reclaimed
as pure and perfect symbols of this wilderness
that must necessarily remain untouched by
human hands.
I think the will, where Wolf gives us a place
to think, not with these two extremes, good
versus evil, but to think about how the truth
of both our own existence as humans and those
Wolf's existence is that it's somewhere in
between.
And that we find ourselves living in a world
that is not wilderness versus culture, but
always somewhere muddling along between the
two.
Real or fiction.
Good or evil.
Man or beast.
Ultimately werewolves are about dichotomies.
They represent the thin boundaries between
the human and inhuman, interior motives and
outward appearance, animal and man, wild and
civilized.
As our perception of these contradictions
changes over time, so too does the werewolf.
The best werewolf movie in the last 10 years,
and luckily it has been a nice, exciting boon
for werewolves in horror, but the best one
might be 2017's Good Manners.
Writer directors Juliana Rojas and Marco Dutra,
they use the werewolf mythology to explore
loneliness and classism, motherhood, and the
horrors of pregnancy, and all of it just gels
into this really grim fairytale-style narrative
structure that's both scary and beautiful.
And I think that that kind of speaks to what
defines the modern werewolf, in that there
really isn't any definition anymore, other
than the core of someone transforming a into
wolf or wolf creature.
The hows and the whys of lycanthropy are now
fully open to interpretation in look and tone.
I'm hopeful that in the future, we're going
to see more positive man into Wolf transformations.
The other thing I'd absolutely love to see
is
far more texts where wearables live alongside
vampires and fairies, and they live alongside
sea monsters and zombies.
For me, that reflects more truly what it is
like living in an intersectional and diverse
society and a society where we can be connected
with a pluralism via the internet and that
these monsters, these creatures that come
from specific identities and cultures have
to learn how to live alongside each other
much.
Like we all doing today,
We’ve come a long way from the first rumblings
of the werewolf in ancient European cultures,
and thankfully, just as far as the persecution
of humans as werewolves.
But what we haven’t lost is the fear—and
the freedom—in the human capacity for dramatic
change.